[Music]
what are you giving what's up is I
thought we agreed biker aids are stupid
the fools who don't like any you saw
that Mary kid scoring chicks with his
back heard about the cash prize and he
decided to do the back ridd behind our
backs I know cuz I thought the same
thing
me too Jesus this is really what it's
come down to you guys whatever happened
to us
what do you move it used to always be
the four of us always now stands moved
to a farm I have anxiety Kenny
nobody really talked to Keaney and then
there's just cap we used to do
everything together
what if we did this like the old days
for bikes
one common theme we could totally own
the bike parade whoa if we order
everything online we have it delivered
tomorrow we need props pyrotechnics the
works yeah we gotta order some badass
spokes on those wheel bumpers I'll start
looking for costumes but family thinking
can't get on your mom's laptop and start
already savers farmers pockets
make sure everyone ships next day
delivery she's gonna be just ideal
attacks you guys
[Music]
myself